you've been to so many places what's it  like out there Alma's miserable  you're either sunburned sleep-deprived  or seasick and after a few days there's  that loosen Asians why do you do it it's  a fear it's intense wish you and the  infinite horizon we must be a sailor - I  take it I don't know that I would  consider myself a sailor oh come on no  you are you want sacrum hm anytime you  think you might want to go sailing it  mean how would you like to sail it is  headed to California verse four thousand  miles is insane I'm saying with me  [Music]  hurricane Raymond is peanut brain into a  category 5  I love you  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  we're not gonna die out here  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]